Jake: 你不吃
Jake: You're not eating?
Jake: 呵呵吃吧
Jake: Hehe, eat up.
Jake: 你也不吃
Jake: You're not eating either.
Jake: 就咱俩吃
Jake: Just the two of us eating.
Lucia: 有可能但我其实肯定也吃不了
Lucia: Maybe, but I actually can't eat much.
Lucia: 多少因为不是很饿
Lucia: Because I'm not very hungry.
Lucia: 但如果完全不吃我可能晚上睡觉
Lucia: But if I don't eat at all, I might have trouble sleeping.
Jake:那咱吃夜宵吧
Jake: Then let's have a late-night snack.
Jake: 要不哈哈哈
Jake: What do you think? Haha.
Lucia:又吃得这么晚
Lucia: Eating so late again.
Lucia: 就是你选择吃什么吧
Lucia: You decide what to eat.
Lucia:哈哈我都行
Lucia: Haha, I'm okay with anything.
Katrina: 我想喝粥
Katrina: I want some porridge.
Jake:咱都吃馄饨呗
Jake: Let's all have wontons.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Lucia: 也行
Lucia: That works too.
Lucia:呵呵呵
Lucia: Hehehe.
Alice:别吧的假呀
Alice: No, don't.
Lucia:我算完了老板
Lucia: I finished, boss.
Lucia:哈哈好
Lucia: Haha, good.
Alice:请
Alice: Please.
Lucia:要给你发详单吗
Lucia: Do you want the detailed bill?
Lucia:654.78
Lucia: 654.78.
Katrina: 你怎么花这么少钱
Katrina: How did you spend so little?
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Huh?
Lucia:可能是因为我我没有怎么点过外卖
Lucia: Maybe because I rarely order takeout.
Lucia:我每次都是大家点的时候
Lucia: I just order when everyone else does.
Lucia:我就跟着点一个嗯
Lucia: I just follow along and get something.
Lucia:我甚至觉得我这个挺多
Lucia: I even think it's quite a lot.
Lucia:因为我加了我的疫苗
Lucia: Because I added my vaccine.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:谢谢老板 实际上我还要在打两针呢
Lucia: Thanks, boss. I still need two more shots.
Jake:好好好行 没问题
Jake: Okay, okay, no problem.
Katrina: 走上去一看就是一堆capo
Katrina: Going up, it's just a bunch of capos.
Lucia:我在接下来这一个月里还要打两针
Lucia: I still need two shots next month.
Katrina: 为什么要交换穿
Katrina: Why swap clothes?
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Shure的女友:你问他嘛想要强盗
Shure: Ask him if he wants to be a robber.
Katrina: 可能他想要体验一下女生的这种感觉
Katrina: Maybe he wants to experience what it's like to be a girl.
Katrina: 但你穿的竟然还好
Katrina: But you actually wear it well.
Katrina: 不是很唯和 啊
Katrina: Not too girly, huh?
Shure的女友:因为这是男款谢谢
Shure: Because it's men's wear, thanks.
Katrina: 噢
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina: 够了哈哈哈
Katrina: That's enough, hahaha.
Katrina: 快走吧
Katrina: Let's go quickly.
Katrina: 修硕哈哈
Katrina: Shure, hahaha.
Katrina: 被你折磨的
Katrina: You've tortured me.
Katrina: 拜拜
Katrina: Bye-bye.
Shure: 拜拜
Shure: Bye-bye.
Katrina: 别哭别哭
Katrina: Don't cry, don't cry.
Katrina: 哈哈哈别哭
Katrina: Hahaha, don't cry.
Katrina: 哈哈哈还下雨吗
Katrina: Hahaha, is it still raining?
Shure: 不下啦
Shure: It's not raining anymore.
Katrina: ok
Katrina: Okay.
Alice:刚刚下雨了吗
Alice: Was it raining just now?
Lucia:刚下了哇
Lucia: It just rained, wow.
Katrina: 哎呦脚都麻了
Katrina: Oh, my foot is numb.
Katrina: 我去我这么多
Katrina: Oh my, I have so much to do.
Alice:所以刚刚在谈啥呀
Alice: So, what were you talking about just now?
Lucia:刚刚在谈报销的事
Lucia: We were talking about reimbursements.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice:没参加也
Alice: I didn't participate.
Tasha:你可以报
Tasha: You can report it.
Lucia:放心吧
Lucia: Don't worry.
Katrina: 把我笑死了
Katrina: You cracked me up.
Alice:啊怎么啦
Alice: Ah, what happened?
Katrina: 拜拜你回来了
Katrina: Bye-bye, you're back.
Jake:拜拜 哈哈
Jake: Bye-bye, haha.
Katrina: 生怕他们再回来烧钱
Katrina: I'm afraid they will come back and burn money again.
Katrina: 我去算我的钱
Katrina: I'm going to count my money.
Alice:收拾东西
Alice: Pack up.
Jake:来 收款码
Jake: Here, the payment code.
Lucia:嗯谢谢老板
Lucia: Mm, thank you, boss.
Lucia:等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a moment.
Lucia:收款码在哪
Lucia: Where's the payment code?
Lucia:哦好像是这个
Lucia: Oh, it seems to be this one.
Alice:现在是要一个
Alice: Now we need one.
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Alice:一个什么吗
Alice: One what?
Alice:怎么报账
Alice: How to get reimbursement?
Alice:是给你账单
Alice: Do you need the invoice?
Lucia:自自己加一下也行
Lucia: You can add it yourself too.
Lucia:哈哈哈对给一个
Lucia: Haha, yeah, give one.
Jake:然后后来给一个账单也行
Jake: Then later give a bill too.
Lucia:行行 对
Lucia: Sure, sure, yeah.
Jake:给一个
Jake: Give one.
Lucia:但是我这都是就是
Lucia: But mine are all just...
Lucia:微信淘宝然后京东这些
Lucia: WeChat, Taobao, and JD, those.
Jake:OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Alice:哎呀别烦我
Alice: Oh, don't bother me.
Jake:多少来着
Jake: How much was it?
Jake:600
Jake: 600.
Lucia:我看一眼上哪去了 654.78
Lucia: Let me check, 654.78.
Jake:可以很精确谢谢
Jake: Very precise, thanks.
Lucia:我在卫生所
Lucia: I'm at the clinic.
Lucia:那是有发票的
Lucia: They have invoices there.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:需要的话可以给你
Lucia: If you need it, I can get it for you.
Jake:用不着
Jake: No need.
Alice:你可以帮我按一下计算器吗我不想
Alice: Can you press the calculator for me? I don't want to.
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Alice:我来吧
Alice: I'll do it.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Jake:记账台是吧
Jake: The ledger, right?
Jake:这就是账台
Jake: This is the ledger.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Mm.
Jake:记账台
Jake: Ledger.
Lucia:我们也要做balance shit吗难道
Lucia: Do we have to do a balance sheet too?
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia:梯子帐
Lucia: Ladder accounts.
Alice:好啦我把账直接发给你吧
Alice: Alright, I'll just send the bill to you.
Jake: 好 呃 你这个很专业
Jake: Okay, uh, you're very professional.
Alice:这是备忘录
Alice: It's a memo.
Alice:就是你可以放图片和文字
Alice: You can put pictures and text in it.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:嗯学习学习
Lucia: Mm, learning, learning.
Alice:这个
Alice: This.
Katrina: 哎呀哎我们直接算了
Katrina: Oh, let's just count it directly.
Katrina: 你需要我们订单纸那个吗
Katrina: Do you need our order paper?
Alice:备忘录里写也行
Alice: Writing it in the memo is fine too.
Katrina: 他不需要的话我们就直接算了
Katrina: If he doesn't need it, we'll just count it directly.
Katrina: 我先点个粥喝
Katrina: I'll order some congee first.
Katrina: 看我的红包
Katrina: Look at my red envelope.
Lucia:我也可以用
Lucia: I can use it too.
Katrina: 一个一新币的红包
Katrina: A one Singapore dollar red envelope.
Jake:嗯啊很多哈哈
Jake: Hmm, there are many, haha.
Alice:咦
Alice: Huh?
Alice:奇怪呢
Alice: That's weird.
Alice:我给你发一个
Alice: I'll send you one.
Alice:为什么是这样的呢
Alice: Why is it like this?
Alice:给你发一个完整版的
Alice: I'll send you the full version.
Jake:呃就你那个店里边
Jake: Uh, just in your store.
Katrina: 你们想吃别的可以点
Katrina: You can order other things if you want.
Jake:就是吃馄饨
Jake: Just wontons.
Jake:大家也没什么想
Jake: No one wants anything else.
Jake:你们想吃什么也行
Jake: You can order whatever you like.
Jake:馄饨就是它
Jake: Wontons it is.
Alice:算了直接截图吧
Alice: Forget it, just take a screenshot.
Lucia:这是啥味的
Lucia: What flavor is this?
Katrina: 虾仁的啊
Katrina: Shrimp.
Lucia:超派虾仁的
Lucia: Super shrimp flavor.
Katrina: 哎大馄饨应该改成小馄饨
Katrina: Hey, big wontons should be changed to small wontons.
Lucia:我也要这个吧
Lucia: I'll take this one too.
Lucia:我要香菜
Lucia: I want cilantro.
Lucia:我好了谢谢
Lucia: I'm done, thank you.
Katrina: 你吃吗嗯
Katrina: Are you eating? Hmm?
Katrina: 你不想吃
Katrina: You don't want to eat?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Katrina: 你呢
Katrina: What about you?
Jake:一碗大馄饨50一颗
Jake: One bowl of big wontons, 50 each.
Tasha:sorry
Tasha: Sorry.
Lucia:没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina: 哎没电了
Katrina: Ah, out of battery.
Lucia:我这也没电了
Lucia: Mine is out of battery too.
Katrina: 还有多的充电宝呢
Katrina: There are more power banks.
Jake:有上楼
Jake: There are upstairs.
Jake:随便拔
Jake: Just unplug one.
Alice:我也弄成PDF
Alice: I'll also make it a PDF.
Jake:好好你来
Jake: Alright, go ahead.
Jake:哈哈哈你拔了
Jake: Haha, you unplugged it.
Alice:因为 那个
Alice: Because that...
Alice:一弄就变马那啥了
Alice: It turns into a horse thingy once you mess with it.
Lucia:嗯截止到目前为止
Lucia: Hmm, up until now.
Lucia:我一个人要的香菜啊
Lucia: I've been the only one asking for cilantro.
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia:没事它是一份一份的对
Lucia: It's okay, it's served in portions, right?
Jake:你你你给我哎哎
Jake: You, you, you, give me, hey, hey.
Jake:呃 唧 好
Jake: Uh, okay, good.
Jake:给钱哈哈
Jake: Pay up, haha.
Tasha:我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Tasha:那还不够还的
Tasha: That's still not enough.
Jake:打钱够不够
Jake: Is the money enough?
Jake:看看
Jake: Check it out.
Tasha:没没坏吧
Tasha: It's not broken, right?
Alice:那就行
Alice: Then it's fine.
Alice:白干
Alice: It's all for nothing.
Jake:白干哈哈哈那何止白干
Jake: All for nothing, haha, more than nothing.
Tasha:何止白干
Tasha: More than nothing.
Lucia:何止白干
Lucia: More than nothing.
Tasha:大钱没进
Tasha: No big money came in.
Lucia:有种跟拼
Lucia: It's like working at Pinduoduo.
Lucia:有种在    打工
Lucia:然后签了竞业协议的感觉
Lucia: And signing a non-compete agreement.
Alice:给
Alice: Here.
Lucia:你们知道那个梗吗
Lucia: Do you know that joke?
Alice:你挑一个
Alice: You pick one.
Lucia:    就是
Lucia: Pinduoduo is...
Lucia:哇我这能说吗
Lucia: Wow, can I say this?
Katrina: 楼上也没有多的充电宝
Katrina: There's no extra power bank upstairs.
Lucia:是影响他们的品牌形象啊
Lucia:就是前几天
Lucia: Just a few days ago.
Jake:怕没有充电宝啊
Jake: Afraid there's no power bank?
Katrina: 都是插了这种的
Katrina: They all plugged in like this.
Katrina: 充电宝插了摄像机的
Katrina: The power banks are plugged into the cameras.
Jake:对对对是的
Jake: Yeah, yeah, that's right.
Katrina: 你可以
Katrina: You can...
Jake:楼上的那个摄像机好像关了是吧
Jake: The camera upstairs seems to be off, right?
Jake: 对楼上的不录了
Jake: Yeah, the one upstairs is not recording.
Katrina: 哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh.
Lucia:就是前前
Lucia: Just before...
Alice:所以怎么弄成PDF呢
Alice: So how do you turn it into a PDF then?
Jake:呃打印
Jake: Uh, print.
Lucia:那 嗯备忘录吗
Lucia: Then, um, memo?
Lucia:备忘录好像可以直接导出成品
Lucia: The memo can be directly exported, it seems.
Alice:导出备忘录我发出的这张图片
Alice: Export the memo, along with the picture I sent.
Jake:来来来来来
Jake: Come on, come on, come on.
Alice:哦 它已经好了
Alice: Oh, it's already done.
Jake:来给你
Jake: Here you go.
Jake:您您继续说
Jake: You, you continue talking.
Alice:我我我怎么弄
Alice: How do I do it?
Lucia:啊没事
Lucia: Ah, it's fine.
Jake:你放这我再给你
Jake: You put it here, I'll give it to you again.
Jake:我给你秀一下
Jake: I'll show you.
Jake:哎接着吧别忘录
Jake: Hey, continue, don't forget to record.
Alice:然后就打印
Alice: Then just print it.
Alice:哦这样啊
Alice: Oh, like this?
Alice:对然后呢
Alice: Yes, then?
Jake:然后选择打印机
Jake: Then choose the printer.
Jake:哦也不用
Jake: Oh, no need.
Jake:就这边直接点
Jake: Just click here directly.
Katrina: 点完了吗
Katrina: Finished clicking?
Jake:就可以发送了
Jake: Then you can send it.
Jake:这边是pdf
Jake: This is the PDF.
Katrina: 我手机呢
Katrina: Where's my phone?
Lucia:啊哦就是就是
Lucia: Ah, oh, that is, that is...
Lucia:前几天网上一个新闻就是
Lucia: A few days ago there was news online about Pinduoduo.
Lucia:就是大家知道竟业协议这回事
Lucia: Do you all know about the non-compete agreement?
Lucia:嗯对靖康可能知道
Lucia: Hmm, yes, Jingkang might know.
Lucia:就是啊
Lucia: So, uh...
Lucia:薇薇之前不知道的话就是没事
Lucia: Weiwei, if you didn't know before, it's fine.
Lucia:这个反正是你到到工作的时候
Lucia: Anyway, you'll only use it when you start working.
Lucia:之后才会才会用到
Lucia: So, some big companies...
Lucia:所以然后就是有的大公司
Lucia: For example, to prevent you from joining...
Lucia:比如说就为了防止你入入职
Lucia: A competing company...
Lucia:跟他有竞争关系的其他公司
Lucia: They will have you sign a non-compete agreement when you join.
Lucia:他在入职时候会跟你签竞业协议就要
Lucia: To prevent high-level employees from leaking trade secrets.
Lucia:就是防止就是这些高层员工泄露商业
Lucia: That's its original design purpose.
Lucia:商业机密
Lucia: Trade secrets.
Lucia:他本身是这样的一个
Lucia: That's its original...
Lucia:就是design purpose是这个
Lucia: Its design purpose is that.
Lucia:然后但是就是
Lucia: But then...
Lucia:有的公司现在就开始滥用这个
Lucia: Some companies are starting to abuse this now.
Lucia:就是即使是基层员工入职
Lucia: Even entry-level employees have to sign it.
Lucia:比如说刚刚刚毕业应届生这种
Lucia: Like fresh graduates, for example.
Lucia:也让他们去签竞业协议
Lucia: They make them sign non-compete agreements.
Lucia:然后因为其实现在就是大家换工
Lucia: And since job-hopping is very common now,
Lucia:换工作是很常见的嘛
Lucia: there have been cases where
Lucia:然后就有之前就有好好好些
Lucia: even regular employees,
Lucia:就是其实很普通的员工
Lucia: after leaving the company,
Lucia:然后他们可能从这公司离职之后
Lucia: end up in a job where their responsibilities
Lucia:然后他进入了一个实际上吧
Lucia: aren't even that related to their old company.
Lucia:他负责的业务
Lucia: The new company's tasks
Lucia:可能跟之前公司也不是那么相关的
Lucia: don't really overlap with the old company's.
Lucia:这么的新公司
Lucia: And these are just entry-level workers,
Lucia:然后就是而且他们就是基层打工人
Lucia: without any access to trade secrets.
Lucia:所以手上也没有什么商业机密
Lucia: But their old employers
Lucia:但是他们的员工司
Lucia: still sue them using the non-compete agreements.
Lucia:就拿这个竞业协议去起诉他们
Lucia: Making them pay damages.
Lucia:然后让他们赔钱
Lucia: It's like they worked for nothing.
Lucia:就相当于是白干
Lucia: Practically for free.
Jake: 白干啊
Jake: For free, huh?
Lucia:对相当于不光白干
Lucia: Yeah, not only for free,
Lucia:还要给员工公司赔钱
Lucia: but they even have to pay their old company.
Lucia:就这个事情
Lucia: This kind of thing
Lucia:前段时间
Lucia: has been happening a lot lately.
Lucia:反正网上说了好几个这样的例子
Lucia: There have been several cases discussed online.
Lucia:都是我刚才说的那个
Lucia: Just like what I mentioned earlier.
Lucia:我就不说一遍了
Lucia: I won't repeat it.
Lucia:这样一会你方便剪
Lucia: So it’s easier for you to edit.
Lucia:哈哈哈好好
Lucia: Hahaha, alright.
Lucia:我场记一下
Lucia: Let me jot that down.
Lucia:我还是挺害怕他们来找我的
Lucia: I'm actually pretty scared they'll come after me.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:我没有
Alice: I don't have that.
Jake:没有没有我把
Jake: No, no, we'll just
Jake:我们把    给逼掉就行
Jake: bleep out Pinduoduo.
Jake:我们把逼给逼掉就行
Jake: We'll just bleep out the name.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:杨老板我来算算你八字吧
Alice: Jake, let me calculate your fortune.
Jake:啊好啊
Jake: Oh, sure.
Jake:怎么算
Jake: How do you do that?
Katrina: 感觉你有点小魔女的感觉
Katrina: It feels like you have a bit of a witch vibe.
Jake:请坐请坐
Jake: Please sit, please sit.
Alice:哦不用不用不用不用不用不用不用哎呀
Alice: Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, oh my!
Jake:请坐大师
Jake: Please sit, master.
Jake:大师请坐
Jake: Master, please sit.
Jake:哈哈大师不得坐着的
Jake: Haha, a master doesn't sit.
Jake:站着大师
Jake: Stand, master.
Jake:没见过站着大师
Jake: Never seen a master standing.
Alice:但你得
Alice: But you have to...
Lucia:但是
Lucia: But...
Alice:你知道你的出生时间吗
Alice: Do you know your birth time?
Jake:我好像不知道
Jake: I don't think I know.
Alice:那拜
Alice: Well then, bye.
Jake:好再见
Jake: Okay, goodbye.
Alice:百搭 直接百搭
Alice: Totally incompatible, totally incompatible.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 可以算我的吗
Katrina: Can you do mine?
Katrina: 我知道我是农历还是阳历
Katrina: I know if it's the lunar calendar or the solar calendar.
Katrina: 呃你得出精确到时间
Katrina: Uh, you need to be precise to the time.
Katrina: 我下午1点出生的
Katrina: I was born at 1 PM.
Katrina: 下午1点可以
Katrina: 1 PM is fine.
Alice:1点前一点后
Alice: Before 1 or after 1?
Katrina: 一点零几分了
Katrina: A few minutes after 1.
Lucia:不过法律意义上说我这应该不算造谣
Lucia: But legally speaking, this shouldn't be considered slander.
Lucia:因为
Lucia: Because...
Lucia:我只是复述了我在网上看到的信息
Lucia: I'm just repeating what I saw online.
Alice:那你的生日是
Alice: So your birthday is...
Katrina: 嗯阳历还是农历
Katrina: Hmm, solar or lunar calendar?
Katrina: 阳历2001
Katrina: Solar, 2001.
Lucia:反正我好多同学都是学法的
Lucia: Anyway, many of my classmates study law.
Lucia:都够组一个律师团了
Lucia: We could form a whole legal team.
Alice:91年12月
Alice: December 1991.
Katrina: 21
Katrina: 21.
Lucia:下午1点
Lucia: 1 PM.
Alice:1点啊 1点无所谓
Alice: 1 PM, huh? 1 PM, it doesn’t matter.
Alice:1点几分都一样
Alice: A few minutes after 1, it's all the same.
Tasha:现在在干嘛
Tasha: What are you doing now?
Katrina: 现在等饭
Katrina: Waiting for food.
Tasha:哦对你们点饭了 哎
Tasha: Oh right, you guys ordered food, huh?
Lucia:你刚才没点吗
Lucia: You didn't order earlier?
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Katrina: 那你可以睡觉
Katrina: Then you can sleep
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay
Katrina: 今天睡了一下午好爽啊
Katrina: I slept all afternoon today, it felt so good
Jake:是确实
Jake: Yeah, it really did
Katrina: 而且醒来都都下雨了
Katrina: And when I woke up, it was raining
Jake:下雨天适合睡觉
Jake: Rainy days are perfect for sleeping
Alice:请求超时
Alice: Request timed out
Alice:我们是现场报销吗
Alice: Are we reimbursing on the spot?
Jake:可以
Jake: Yes
Katrina: 哎呦 哎我买一支彩色笔好像没看见
Katrina: Oh, I bought a colored pen but I can't seem to find it
Katrina: 一支彩色笔 没送吗
Katrina: A colored pen, wasn't it delivered?
Lucia:没送吗
Lucia: Wasn't it delivered?
Katrina: 哎取了取了
Katrina: Oh, I got it
Katrina: 我听谁说好像看见了
Katrina: I heard someone say they saw it
Lucia:好像看了但是
Lucia: It seemed like I saw it but
Lucia:后来又放哪去就不知道了
Lucia: Later, I don't know where it went
Jake:这边还有一袋
Jake: There's another bag here
Jake:不知道是什么
Jake: Not sure what's inside
Jake:不知道谁垫的
Jake: Don't know who left it
Katrina: 我的我的
Katrina: It's mine, it's mine
Katrina: 我今天早上找我的牙膏没找到
Katrina: I was looking for my toothpaste this morning and couldn't find it
Lucia:哦我还买了碘伏和生理盐水
Lucia: Oh, I also bought iodine and saline solution
Lucia:不过那东西会也只有我用了
Lucia: But I might be the only one using it
Lucia:没事就算我那个啥也行
Lucia: It's fine even if I...
Lucia:反正他也就一新币
Lucia: Anyway, it only costs one dollar
Tasha:一新币
Tasha: One dollar?
Lucia:对一新币
Lucia: Yes, one dollar
Lucia:算了不管他了
Lucia: Forget it, never mind
Lucia:不算了
Lucia: Doesn't matter
Jake:对回新加坡少坐一次公交车
Jake: Yeah, save a bus ride in Singapore
Jake:少坐半次公交车
Jake: Save half a bus ride
Katrina: 然后我还买了花呢
Katrina: And I also bought flowers
Lucia:我美团上的单子比较少刚就忘
Lucia: I had fewer orders on Meituan, so I forgot
Lucia:算了不也没关系
Lucia: Never mind, it's okay
Lucia:哈哈哈不用
Lucia: Haha, no need
Lucia:争取用这个哈哈哈
Lucia: I'll try to use this, haha
Lucia:觉得我现在又饱又饿好奇怪啊
Lucia: I feel both full and hungry at the same time, it's so weird
Jake:就是几个胃
Jake: Like having multiple stomachs
Lucia:其实我有点想吃东西
Lucia: Actually, I'm a bit hungry.
Lucia:但是就是我没有那种特别饿的感觉
Lucia: But it's just that I don't feel that particularly hungry.
Lucia:刚才吃了一大块
Lucia: I just ate a big piece earlier.
Tasha:好腻刚刚吃了一块
Tasha: It was so greasy, I just had one piece.
Jake:最多吃一个
Jake: At most, just eat one.
Jake:那确实一天最多吃一个
Jake: Yeah, one a day at most.
Lucia:很好吃但是吃多了确实会有一点
Lucia: It's really tasty, but having too much is a bit...
Lucia:太甜了
Lucia: Too sweet.
Lucia:糖分摄入超标
Lucia: Sugar intake overload.
Tasha:然后今天晚上就把房子拆了就行是吧
Tasha: So, we'll just take down the house tonight, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha:那我现在去拆
Tasha: Then I'll take it down now.
Tasha:然后晚上就不用拆了
Tasha: And then we don't need to do it tonight.
Jake:对 好
Jake: Yeah, that's good.
Jake:现在拆吧
Jake: Take it down now.
Jake:合影合影
Jake: Group photo, group photo.
Lucia:冲冲冲
Lucia: Let's go, let's go!
Tasha:你也拆
Tasha: You take it down too.
Jake:可以报
Jake: Can report.
Lucia:我也拆
Lucia: I'll take it down too.
Jake:怎么报
Jake: How to report?
Jake:就你你给我那PDF你写一个
Jake: Just, you give me that PDF, you write one.
Jake:总帐呗
Jake: Total account.
Katrina: 我这个太杂了
Katrina: Mine is too messy.
Katrina: 我天
Katrina: Oh my god.
Alice:就在568.19 刚摁的这些线
Alice: It's at 568.19, these wires just pressed.
Jake:就就这些是吧 对
Jake: Just these, right? Yeah.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Tasha:我手机也呢
Tasha: Where's my phone?
Tasha:啊哦在这
Tasha: Ah, oh, here it is.
Alice:什么鬼这是
Alice: What the heck is this?
Lucia:哎我水杯在哪来着到底
Lucia: Hey, where's my water bottle again?
Lucia:拆家好累啊
Lucia: Moving out is so exhausting.
Jake:装家累还是拆家累
Jake: Is moving in or out more tiring?
Jake:都挺累的
Jake: Both are pretty exhausting.
Lucia:而且关键我那个老掉
Lucia: And the key thing is, mine keeps falling apart.
Lucia:所以相当于我造了好多遍
Lucia: So it's like I have to do it over and over.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:躺会吧小姐姐
Alice: Take a break, girl.
Lucia:重得造家
Lucia: I have to rebuild it again.
Jake:你现在可以拆家了
Jake: Now you can move out again.
Lucia:我想养比格
Lucia: I want to get a beagle.
Lucia:让他帮我拆
Lucia: Let it help me move out.
Jake:那可没法装
Jake: Then you won't be able to move in.
Lucia:所以比格会拆家
Lucia: So, beagles can move out.
Jake:但是你怎么装
Jake: But how will you move in?
Jake:你没法装
Jake: You can't move in.
Jake:拆了之后你还能装上吗
Jake: Can you put everything back after moving out?
Katrina: 对就是他
Katrina: Exactly, it's him.
Lucia:他可能不一定按照你期望的方式拆哦
Lucia: He might not move out the way you expect.
Lucia:一些出其不意的拆法
Lucia: Some surprising ways to move out.
Alice:又下起来了
Alice: It's raining again.
Lucia:咪咪
Lucia: Kitty.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:喵喵
Alice: Meow meow.
Lucia:我申请楼下支援一个箱子
Lucia: I'm requesting a box from downstairs.
Alice:咪咪
Alice: Kitty.
Alice:喵喵
Alice: Meow meow.
Jake: 为啥没声呀
Jake: Why is there no sound?
Alice:小喵喵
Alice: Little kitty.
Jake: 一点声都没有
Jake: Not a sound.
Alice:喵喵
Alice: Meow meow.
Jake:你再试试
Jake: Try again.
Alice:咪咪咪咪喵喵喵
Alice: Kitty kitty, meow meow meow.
Alice:吃吧
Alice: Eat.
Alice:喵喵
Alice: Meow meow
Jake:咳咳
Jake: Ahem
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice:吃吧吃吧别怕
Alice: Eat, eat, don't be scared
Alice:可以吃可以吃可以吃
Alice: You can eat, you can eat, you can eat
Alice:别怕呀
Alice: Don't be scared
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Alice:吃吧吃吧可以吃
Alice: Eat, eat, you can eat
Lucia:有点下雨了
Lucia: It's starting to rain a bit
Lucia:哎听这声音算了不看他了
Lucia: Oh, listen to that sound, never mind, don't look at him
Alice:看他他又不吃
Alice: Look at him, he's not eating
Alice:把这个收回去吧
Alice: Let's take this back
Alice:波比波比波波比波
Alice: Bobby, Bobby, Bob, Bob, Bobby, Bob
Alice:嗯Lucia
Alice: Hmm, Lucia
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Alice:你要
Alice: Do you
Alice:需要帮忙收拾东西吗
Alice: Need help cleaning up?
老板:柯欣什么时候
Boss: When is Ke Xin
Lucia:需要需要你来陪我玩
Lucia: I need you to come play with me
Lucia:哈哈啊
Lucia: Haha
Lucia:需要你来陪我玩
Lucia: I need you to come play with me
Alice:玩 玩什么
Alice: Play what?
Lucia:玩
Lucia: Play
Alice:猫捉老鼠
Alice: Cat and mouse
Jake:猫捉老鼠
Jake: Cat and mouse
Lucia:可以谁当猫谁当老鼠
Lucia: Okay, who will be the cat and who will be the mouse?
Jake: 猫捉老鼠
Jake: Cat and mouse
Alice:我当狗反正
Alice: I'll be the dog anyway
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia:我要把这个拿上去
Lucia: I'm going to take this upstairs
Lucia:要跟我一起来吗
Lucia: Do you want to come with me?
Alice:可以我可以帮你们收拾
Alice: Sure, I can help you clean up
Alice:我差不多了
Alice: I'm almost done
Jake:好
Jake: Alright
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Alice:你需要吗
Alice: Do you need anything?
Alice:我收拾完了
Alice: I've finished cleaning up
Lucia:嗯大家都这么快
Lucia: Hmm, everyone is so fast
Alice:来吧
Alice: Come on
Alice:冲冲冲冲
Alice: Let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go
Lucia:我其实是想试一下
Lucia: I actually want to try something
Lucia:这箱子能不能装下我的那个啥
Lucia: See if this box can fit my... you know
Lucia:我该拆的东西倒也不是特别的多
Lucia: I don't really have a lot to dismantle
Lucia:就把墙上那些都取下来就行
Lucia: Just need to take down those things from the wall
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright
Lucia:但关键就是我有一个这个
Lucia: But the key thing is I have this
Jake:我要把相机拆了来来啊
Jake: I need to take apart the camera, come on
Lucia:我要把它
Lucia: I have to...
Lucia:对不起
Lucia: Sorry
Jake: 看看怎么拆
Jake: Let's see how to take it apart
Lucia:这个可以这样
Lucia: This can be done like this
Lucia:先随便盖一下
Lucia: Just cover it up for now
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Lucia:推到一边就好
Lucia: Push it to the side, it's fine
Jake:我不知道怎么拆相机啊
Jake: I don't know how to take apart the camera
Lucia:我把你的礼物盒粘在那里了
Lucia: I stuck your gift box over there
Alice:你需要帮
Alice: Do you need help
Alice:你那个需要拆吗
Alice: Does that need to be dismantled
Alice:呃这个要拆的
Alice: Uh, this one needs to be taken apart
Lucia:好我上去吧
Lucia: Okay, I'll go up
Alice:好的谢谢你
Alice: Alright, thank you
Jake:要不然就直接这么
Jake: Otherwise, just do this directly
Jake:哎呀要不然就直接卸了吧
Jake: Ah, forget it, just take it off directly
Jake:这个东西要给他弄下
Jake: This thing needs to be taken down
Jake:但是我不知道怎么弄下
Jake: But I don't know how to take it down
Alice:我的东西
Alice: My stuff
Alice:应该对放在哪里
Alice: Should be placed where
Lucia:糟糕这个放不下
Lucia: Oh no, this doesn't fit
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice:你是要寄回去还是拿回去啊
Alice: Are you sending it back or taking it with you
Lucia:我没想好
Lucia: I haven't decided yet
Jake:这个得需要用个小铲子
Jake: This needs a small shovel
Lucia:我觉得这个这个东西比较占地方
Lucia: I think this thing takes up a lot of space
Lucia:我可能啧拿可能不太方便
Lucia: It might be inconvenient to carry
Lucia:但是系的话其实也不是很方便
Lucia: But tying it isn't very convenient either
Lucia:所以先这样放一下
Lucia: So let's just put it here for now
Lucia:珠子
Lucia: The beads
Jake:这粘的确实结实不会掉
Jake: This is glued so firmly it won't fall off
Jake:所以现在就不会掉
Jake: So now it won't fall off
Jake:先扔到这吧
Jake: Just throw it here for now
Jake:没有一点办法
Jake: There's no way.
Lucia:我刚才光把那个柜子拆拆掉就很费力
Lucia: I just spent so much effort dismantling that cabinet.
Jake:那真的吗
Jake: Really?
Alice:你把刘婷叫上来
Alice: You should call Liu Ting up here.
Lucia:没事已经差不多了
Lucia: It's okay, it's almost done.
Alice:谢谢大家
Alice: Thank you, everyone.
Alice:看着她闲我难受
Lucia:你们是本科同学还是
Lucia: Were you guys classmates in college or...?
Lucia:不是我们是可以偶然的
Lucia: No, we just met by chance.
Jake:不要变
Jake: Don't change.
Alice:偶然认识的
Alice: We met by chance.
Lucia:是的
Lucia: Yes.
Alice:偶然间就我们俩才认识一个多月
Alice: We only got to know each other a little over a month ago.
Jake: 哎 啊
Jake: Oh, ah.
Alice:俺俩竟然已经同床共枕了
Alice: And we already share a bed.
Lucia:我以为你们认识好长时间
Lucia: I thought you guys knew each other for a long time.
Jake: 哎 我来我来
Jake: Oh, let me, let me.
Lucia:可能是舍友真的特别熟
Lucia: Maybe because you’re roommates, you’re really close.
Alice:其实才认识一个多月
Alice: Actually, we've only known each other for a little over a month.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Alice:但我们两个已经嗯同床共枕了
Alice: But we've already been sharing a bed.
Alice:但是
Alice: But...
Alice:有的人就是觉得跟他很快就能很好的朋友
Alice: Some people just feel like they can quickly become good friends.
Lucia:对是的啊
Lucia: Yes, exactly.
Alice:波比波啊哈哈
Alice: Bobbi-bo, haha.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Lucia:而且有的朋友
Lucia: And some friends...
Alice:什么扎着我的脚啊
Alice: What's poking my foot?
Lucia:小心没事啊
Lucia: Be careful, it's okay.
Alice:浅浅的不是那种锋利的
Alice: It's shallow, not sharp.
Jake: 我是得买个铲子吧
Jake: I should buy a shovel, right?
Alice:只是有点硌
Alice: Just a bit pokey.
Alice:脚脚
Alice: My foot.
Jake: 那种挖的那种
Jake: The digging kind.
Lucia:这可能是这个
Lucia: Maybe it's this.
Alice:没事你先待会再收拾吧
Alice: It's okay, you can tidy up later.
Alice:因为我还没给你弄完呢
Alice: Because I haven't finished with you yet.
Alice:你到时候再
Alice: You can do it later.
Lucia:这个美纹纸胶性其实还挺强的
Lucia: This masking tape is actually pretty strong.
Lucia:就是如果粘的时间长了
Lucia: If it sticks for a long time,
Lucia:它就会在那个地方
Lucia: it will leave residue on the surface.
Alice:反正我的东西就那些小装饰
Alice: Anyway, my stuff is just those little decorations.
Alice:那个桌布啊啥的
Alice: Like the tablecloth and stuff.
Alice:我就让刘婷拿回她家了
Alice: I asked Liu Ting to take them back to her place.
Lucia:哦她家就在北京是吧
Lucia: Oh, she lives in Beijing, right?
Alice:对刘婷他家有个比这还大的别墅
Alice: Yeah, Liu Ting's place has an even bigger villa than this.
Lucia:哇好好
Lucia: Wow, that's nice.
Alice:真是的深藏不露
Alice: Seriously, she's been hiding it all along.
Alice:来到这我才知道
Alice: I only found out when I came here.
Alice:她说她家也有一个这样的
Alice: She said her place is just like this.
Lucia:下次可以去她家吗
Lucia: Can we visit her place next time?
Alice:不知道哈哈
Alice: I don't know, haha.
Lucia:开玩笑
Lucia: Just kidding.
Alice:她家在昌平我把她家记错了
Alice: Her place is in Changping, I mixed it up.
Alice:她还怨了我呢
Alice: She was annoyed with me.
Alice:我总觉得她是房山的
Alice: I always thought she was from Fangshan.
Alice:她说她没去过房山
Alice: She said she's never been to Fangshan.
Lucia:哎我我有一个舍友也是
Lucia: Hey, I have a roommate too.
Alice:坏了我在这说她坏话她不知道
Alice: Oh no, I'm badmouthing her, she doesn't know.
Alice:她应该不知道
Alice: She probably doesn't know.
Alice:刘婷可好玩了
Alice: Liu Ting is really fun.
Alice:刘婷看着大大咧咧的但是很细心
Alice: Liu Ting seems careless but is actually very attentive.
Alice:很
Alice: Very
Alice:体贴
Alice: thoughtful.
Jake:为什么
Jake: Why?
Lucia:感觉她好好
Lucia: She seems so nice.
Lucia:对感觉大家都好好
Lucia: Yeah, everyone seems nice.
Lucia:但是你们俩真的就是
Lucia: But you two really are
Alice:臭味相投
Alice: Perfectly matched.
Alice:不是特别合拍觉得
Alice: Not exactly in sync, I think.
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
Lucia:所以我真的以为你们好像就很熟
Lucia: So I really thought you two were very familiar.
Lucia:可能是认识好长时间的朋友那种
Lucia: Like long-time friends or something.
Alice:她拉屎没带纸
Alice: She didn't bring toilet paper.
Jake:哎呀我靠
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Alice:点名让我去
Alice: She specifically asked me to bring it.
Alice:哈哈哈递纸
Alice: Haha, to hand her the paper.
Alice:我真服了
Alice: I'm really speechless.
Lucia:这些鱼可以折起来
Lucia: These fish can be folded.
Lucia:哎呀好多东西啊
Lucia: Wow, there's so much stuff!
Alice:慢慢来嗯
Alice: Take it slow, yeah.
Lucia:这地底下掉了个啥玩意
Lucia: What fell on the floor?
Lucia:哦竟然是我的鞋
Lucia: Oh, it's my shoe!
Lucia:算了一会再管它
Lucia: Forget it, I'll deal with it later.
Alice:你买好
Alice: Did you buy it?
Alice:哦呦小心
Alice: Oh, careful!
Alice:没事呦呦呦
Alice: It's okay, it's okay.
Alice:重心不稳
Alice: Your balance is off.
Alice:你买好回家的票了吗
Alice: Did you buy the ticket home?
Lucia:没有
Lucia: No.
Lucia:但是我肯定明天就回家了
Lucia: But I'm definitely going home tomorrow.
Alice:不急
Alice: No rush.
Lucia:我现在没决定好哪一趟
Lucia: I haven't decided which trip yet.
Lucia:因为咱们这
Lucia: Because here...
Lucia:我查了一下
Lucia: I checked.
Lucia:从咱们这到北京西站大概一个多小时
Lucia: From here to Beijing West Station is about an hour.
Lucia:但我不知道我几点钟能出发
Lucia: But I don't know what time I can leave.
Lucia:所以还没买
Lucia: So I haven't bought it yet.
Alice:我觉得一个小时都比较正常了
Alice: I think an hour is pretty normal.
Lucia:而且因为东西还没完全收拾好
Lucia: And I haven't finished packing everything yet.
Alice:啊啊那边还有
Alice: Ah, there's more over there.
Lucia:谢谢 宝
Lucia: Thanks, darling.
Lucia:啊那我也上去好了
Lucia: Okay, I'll go up then.
Lucia:我这边网那些也拆好了
Lucia: I've also taken down the network here.
Alice:没事大的
Alice: No problem, it's a big deal.
Lucia:这我你看我都没敢那个啥
Lucia: Look, I didn't even dare to...
Lucia:我这按一下这按了一下啊
Lucia: I pressed this, pressed it.
Alice:还都是那个啥的
Alice: It's still the same.
Lucia:对看他都是撕的
Lucia: Yeah, see, it's all torn.
Jake:哎呦我去 掑下来了
Jake: Oh no, it came off.
Lucia:因为就是这几张是那种就是白底的
Lucia: Because these few are the ones with white backgrounds.
Alice:对如果上面有白底
Alice: Yeah, if there's a white background.
Lucia:就很容易明显的看出来
Lucia: It's very easy to see.
Alice:撕这个就得快准狠
Alice: You have to be quick and precise when tearing this.
Alice:越慢越好
Alice: The slower, the better.
Lucia:好有经验
Lucia: So experienced.
Lucia:那几张都是就是
Lucia: Those few are just...
Alice: 好了还有什么需要弄掉的吗
Alice: Alright, is there anything else that needs to be removed?
Jake:咱就先试试
Jake: Let's try it first.
Alice:啊可以了
Alice: Ah, it's fine.
Jake:谢谢就这些
Jake: Thanks, that's it.
Lucia:然后剩下我可能就
Lucia: Then the rest, I might just...
Jake:我问问
Jake: I'll ask.
Lucia:你要收拾
Lucia: You need to tidy up.
Lucia:对收拾收拾装一装
Lucia: Yes, tidy up and pack.
Jake:他们知道我们这么贴的
Jake: They know we stick it like this.
Lucia:不过装箱子其实好装
Lucia: But actually, packing the boxes is easy.
Lucia:因为因为就是有一些零碎的
Lucia: Because there are some small items.
Lucia:这种一次性用品就不要了
Lucia: We can just discard these disposable items.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:好我来拆相机
Jake: Okay, I'll dismantle the camera.
Alice:好现在可以做什么
Alice: Alright, what can we do now?
Jake:行吧
Jake: Alright then.
Jake:帮我拆相机OK
Jake: Help me dismantle the camera, okay?
Jake:呃拆相机
Jake: Uh, dismantle the camera.
Jake:哎包包
Jake: Hey, the bag.
Jake:哎呦我靠 什么
Jake: Oh my, what...
Jake:嗯拆完了
Jake: Hmm, it's dismantled.
Alice:趁我走之前
Alice: Before I leave.
Jake:你什么时候走
Jake: When are you leaving?
Alice:我嗯今天晚上
Alice: I, uh, tonight.
Jake:吃完饭走是吧
Jake: After dinner, right?
Alice:嗯对吃吧吃吧
Alice: Yeah, let's eat.
Jake:你不是点了吗
Jake: Didn't you order?
Jake:你不吃
Jake: Aren't you eating?
Alice:点过了
Alice: I ordered.
Alice:但是我你要说具体几点的话那无所谓
Alice: But if you want a specific time, it doesn't matter.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh dear.
Jake: 就转转先
Jake: Just turn it first.
Jake:先给它转一下
Jake: Turn it first.
Jake:呃右边有一个
Jake: Uh, there's one on the right.
Jake:啊对
Jake: Ah, yes.
Lucia:那我来拆这个好不好
Lucia: So, can I open this?
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Sure, thank you.
Lucia:那么我就上桌了
Lucia: Then I'll get on the table.
Jake:上桌
Jake: Get on the table.
Lucia:哎呀好激动呀
Lucia: Oh, I'm so excited!
Lucia:好久没有上过桌了哈哈哈
Lucia: I haven't been on the table in a long time, hahaha.
Lucia:所以是是就是撕下来么
Lucia: So, do I just tear this off?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:呃你你先拽下来你先把相机拽下来
Jake: Uh, you, you need to pull this down first, pull down the camera first.
Lucia:先把相机
Lucia: Pull down the camera first.
Jake:拽拽拽拽
Jake: Pull, pull, pull, pull.
Jake:它有一个这个口
Jake: There's an opening here.
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my goodness!
Lucia:这样吗
Lucia: Like this?
Jake:还有一个这个东西
Jake: There's also this thing.
Alice:老板
Alice: Boss.
Alice:这个要是粘真的粘在墙上都得赔死了
Alice: If this really sticks to the wall, it would cost a fortune to remove.
Jake:那可不能粘在墙
Jake: It can't be stuck to the wall.
Alice::巨巨黏
Alice: It's super sticky.
Jake: 对吧
Jake: Right?
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Lucia:哦我知道你说的哪个了嗯
Lucia: Oh, I know which one you're talking about, mm-hmm.
Alice:这个怎么弄
Alice: How do you do this?
Lucia:我可以先把这个线
Lucia: Can I first take this wire...
Lucia:这线线连相机这头
Lucia: This wire connected to the camera.
Lucia:我可以拔吗
Lucia: Can I unplug it?
Jake: 可以拔
Jake: You can unplug it.
Lucia:因为感觉这个钮不是特别好转
Lucia: Because it feels like this button doesn't turn well.
Lucia:别我别我把线给它转断了
Lucia: I don't want to twist the wire until it breaks.
对Jake:
Jake: Right.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Mm-hmm.
Lucia:什么锁
Lucia: What lock?
Lucia:卫生所在
Lucia: Bathroom is there.
Lucia:我给你发个定位吧
Lucia: I'll send you the location.
Alice:你怎么了
Alice: What's wrong with you?
Lucia:啊这个现在也不会不会掉下来
Lucia: Ah, this won't fall off now.
Alice:这个你打车去很慢
Alice: Taking a taxi there is slow.
Alice:就是走路去很近
Alice: Walking is very close.
Lucia:这现在不会掉下来吧
Lucia: This won't fall off now, right?
Lucia:我把这个取下来了啊
Lucia: I'll take this down now, okay?
Alice:哎呦我的妈
Alice: Oh my gosh
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn
Lucia:我我去给雨轩发一下那个定位去
Lucia: I'll send the location to Yuxuan
Jake:好好好
Jake: Okay, okay
Jake:咱陪他一起去
Jake: We'll go with him
Lucia:对
Lucia: Right
Lucia:要不然我送他过去
Lucia: Otherwise, I can take him there
Lucia:因为我走过一次
Lucia: Since I've been there once
Lucia:我比较熟
Lucia: I'm more familiar with it
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright
Lucia:哎呦这个真的
Lucia: Oh my, this is really...
Alice:这个黏的
Alice: This is sticky
Jake:哎呦我靠
Jake: Oh damn
Jake:这个这个
Jake: This, this
Lucia:我之前是发给发给那个同学
Lucia: I previously sent it to that classmate
Lucia:叫什么来着
Lucia: What's the name again?
Lucia:就是染了头发
Lucia: The one who dyed their hair
Alice:XBZ
Alice: XBZ
Lucia:一下想不起来了
Lucia: I can't remember now
Lucia:有点着急
Lucia: Feeling a bit anxious
Jake:竹哥
Jake: Brother Zhu
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh dear
Alice:好难呢
Alice: This is so hard
Lucia:找找一下我刚才的聊天记录
Lucia: Let me check my chat history
Jake:他现在是我哥
Jake: Now he's like my brother
Jake:这这你你是我姐一样
Jake: You're like my sister now
Jake:哈哈 牛逼 哎呦
Jake: Haha, awesome, oh my
Alice:这个怎么弄下来
Alice: How do we get this down?
Alice:你可以给刘婷发个消息吗
Alice: Can you send a message to Liu Ting?
Alice:让她上来帮忙
Alice: Ask her to come up and help
Lucia:稍等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a moment
Lucia:我想把这个
Lucia: I want to do this
Jake:对先
Jake: Yeah, first
Jake:咱先救人
Jake: Let's save the person first
Lucia:嗯 好  对
Lucia: Mm, okay, right
Jake:他在哪啊
Jake: Where is he?
Jake:刘婷
Jake: Liu Ting
Alice:楼底下呢
Alice: Downstairs
Jake:那一会要下去我叫她
Jake: Then I'll call her when we go down
Jake:嚯这个很顺利
Jake: Wow, this is going smoothly
Alice:这个粘空调上的
Alice: This sticks to the air conditioner.
Jake:我来试试
Jake: Let me try.
Jake:let me try一下
Jake: Let me try it.
Alice:你你试
Alice: You, you try.
Jake:我试试
Jake: I'll try.
Jake:我试试这个胶确实牛逼
Jake: I'll try, this glue is really amazing.
Jake:这胶可贵了
Jake: This glue is expensive.
Alice:try半天就try这么点
Alice: After trying for so long, you only tried this much?
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Lucia:呃我给你发了一个定位
Lucia: Uh, I sent you a location.
Lucia:然后
Lucia: And then...
Jake:咱一块去吧好
Jake: Let's go together, okay?
Jake:就这么粗暴
Jake: It's that simple and rough.
Alice:但是那个呢
Alice: But what about that one?
Jake:不管
Jake: Doesn't matter.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake:没有
Jake: Nope.
Jake:就这个这个
Jake: Just this one.
Jake:问问管别墅的人他们有没有法子
Jake: Ask the people who manage the villa if they have a solution.
Jake:他们可能拆过这种东西
Jake: They might have removed this kind of thing before.
Alice:什么干啥
Alice: What are you doing?
Jake:就是我们撕完之后他剩下来一个
Jake: After we peel it off, there's some left.
Lucia:哦这个这个可能可以啊OK
Lucia: Oh, this one, this one might work, okay.
Jake:这个已经没了
Jake: This one's already gone.
Jake:哦这个这个
Jake: Oh, this one, this one.
Lucia:那个可能可以用
Lucia: That one might work.
Lucia:就是吹风机吹一下
Lucia: Just blow it with a hairdryer.
Lucia:然后看能不能撕下来
Lucia: And see if it can be peeled off.
Lucia:但是不是100%能成功
Lucia: But it's not 100% guaranteed to work.
Jake:OK OK问问他问问他
Jake: OK OK, ask him, ask him.
Jake:谢谢各位帮忙做苦力
Jake: Thanks everyone for helping with the labor.
Jake:这纯纯大苦力
Jake: This is purely hard labor.
Alice:哎
Alice: Hey.
Lucia:哎呀
Lucia: Oh dear.
Jake:我又靠
Jake: I'm leaning on it again.
Jake:这边卫生所设施怎么样
Jake: How are the facilities at the health center here?
Lucia:呃呃好有点一言难尽
Lucia: Uh, uh, it's a bit hard to describe.
Lucia:大家一会看一眼
Lucia: Everyone can take a look later.
Lucia:要不要采药吗
Lucia: Do you want to pick herbs?
Lucia:要也可以采一下
Lucia: If you want, we can pick some.
Jake:没事小小小小问题
Jake: It's nothing, just a minor issue.
Lucia:他们肯定那个什么
Lucia: They're definitely, you know...
Lucia:就是那个卫生所他在装修
Lucia: The clinic is being renovated.
Lucia:所以就是进去之后它有点吵
Lucia: So it's a bit noisy when you go in.
Alice:干啥
Alice: What are you doing?
Lucia:然后你 我找个伞
Lucia: Then you... I'll find an umbrella.
Alice:你干什么来
Alice: What are you doing here?
Lucia:我伞在箱子里
Lucia: My umbrella is in the box.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈稍安勿躁
Lucia: Haha, calm down.
Alice:稍安勿躁
Alice: Calm down.
Alice:我的
Alice: Mine.
Alice:哈哈哈你别挡道
Alice: Haha, don't block the way.
Alice:要去要去医院哈哈哈
Alice: We need to go to the hospital, haha.
Alice:老玩这抽象
Alice: Always playing around abstractly.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice:你先坐那吧
Alice: You sit there first.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice:来来来
Alice: Come on, come on.
Alice:坐
Alice: Sit.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice:嗯待会还得下去
Alice: Hmm, we'll have to go down later.
Alice:哎
Alice: Oh.
Alice:都弄掉
Alice: Get rid of all that.
Lucia:这袜子穿着穿着突然就烂了
Lucia: These socks just suddenly ripped while I was wearing them.
Jake:可以你觉得可以吧
Jake: It's okay, do you think it's okay?
Jake:要大家捐
Jake: Everyone should donate.
Jake:捐几件衣服
Jake: Donate some clothes.
Jake:怕你冷着
Jake: So you don't get cold.
Alice:上面是不是拆完了
Alice: Is the top part dismantled?
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Jake:就放到那桌上
Jake: Just put it on that table.
Alice:下面吧
Alice: Put it below, right?
Jake:下面三人还是别拆了
Jake: The three people downstairs should leave it for now.
Jake:晚上再拆
Jake: We'll dismantle it tonight.
Alice:告诉你一个消息
Alice: Let me tell you some news.
Alice:刘婷我要下去了
Alice: Liu Ting, I need to go down.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:来
Alice: Come on.
Alice:不是我没给你发消息
Alice: It's not that I didn't send you a message.
Alice:你咋上来了
Alice: How did you come up here?
Alice:因为你听见了
Alice: Because you heard it.
Lucia:哦你不是让我给刘婷发消息么
Lucia: Oh, didn't you want me to message Liu Ting?
Alice:对啊我还以为我俩的脑电波交流了
Alice: Yeah, I thought we were communicating telepathically.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:那是真的
Jake: That’s true.
Alice:我我我去吧
Alice: I'll go, I'll go.
Jake:你你别动啊
Jake: No, don’t move.
Jake:你你
Jake: Stay, stay.
Alice:我去吧
Alice: I'll go.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Alice:她在哪啊
Alice: Where is she?
Jake:雨轩你在哪
Jake: Yuxuan, where are you?
Jake:我的3号房在哪
Jake: Where is my room number 3?
Alice:你是不是急性
Alice: Are you in a hurry?
Jake:你你现在又好了是吧
Jake: Are you feeling better now?
Alice:肠胃炎呢
Alice: Is it acute...
Alice:可能是感觉像是
Alice: ...gastroenteritis?
Jake:你先坐着歇着
Jake: You sit and rest first.
Jake:你别乱跑了
Jake: Don't run around.
Alice:5 53号楼在哪里
Alice: Where is building 553?
Jake:哎我去呢
Jake: Oh, I’ll go.
Jake:我去你我去你歇着
Jake: I'll go, you rest.
Jake:别别别搞什么搞什么
Jake: Don't, don't mess around.
Alice:好像知道又好像不知道
Alice: It seems like I know, but I don't.
Jake:哎左拐
Jake: Turn left.
Alice:这
Alice: This way?
Jake:左拐对
Jake: Yes, turn left.
Alice:这是左
Alice: This is left.
Jake:哎嗯
Jake: Yes, right.
Jake:就你第一回拿快递
Jake: Is this your first time picking up a package?
Alice:不是
Alice: No.
Jake:第一回拿外卖
Jake: First time getting takeout?
Alice:不是啊
Alice: No.
Jake:那那那你没点53号
Jake: Then how come you missed building 53?
Alice:但是他说53我就不知道在哪
Alice: But when he said 53, I didn't know where it was.
Jake:我31他到门口去了
Jake: I told him 31, he went to the entrance.
Jake:这就是53
Jake: This is 53.
Alice:都是他们家的吗
Alice: Is all of this their house?
Jake:对这一排都是他们家
Jake: Yes, this whole row is theirs.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Right.
Jake:是53
Jake: It's 53.
Lucia:呃雨轩你走路过去还方便吗
Lucia: Uh Yuxuan, is it convenient for you to walk there?
Lucia:哎还还是我们要不然搭车去之类的
Lucia: Hey, or should we take a cab or something?
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Lucia:其实我觉得走过去比搭车快
Lucia: Actually, I think walking is faster than taking a cab.
Lucia:我那天觉得 谢谢
Lucia: That's what I thought the other day. Thank you.
Lucia:但是我害怕你 就是
Lucia: But I'm worried that you might...
Jake:没了
Jake: That's it.
Alice:没了
Alice: That's it.
Lucia:就是着凉什么的
Lucia: ...catch a cold or something.
Jake:慢走 有吧
Jake: Take care. Is there?
Jake:啊 有啊 哎呦
Jake: Ah, yes, there is. Oops.
Lucia:我们路上还要啊录这个吗
Lucia: Do we need to keep recording this on the way?
Lucia:老板人呢
Lucia: Where's the boss?
Lucia:跑多远
Lucia: How far did he go?
Jake:这个这单多远
Jake: How far is this order?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:好行拜拜
Jake: Alright, bye-bye.
Jake:拜拜
Jake: Bye-bye.
Lucia:我们路上还需要录这个吗
Lucia: Do we need to keep recording this on the way?
Jake:啊 等会 说什么
Jake: Uh, wait, what did you say?
Lucia:我们去卫生所
Lucia: We're going to the clinic.
Lucia:路上还要需要录这个吗
Lucia: Do we need to keep recording this on the way?
Lucia:还是可以停掉之类的
Lucia: Or can we stop it or something?
Jake:你再带着吧
Jake: Just keep it on.
Jake:带着没电拉倒了就
Jake: If it runs out of battery, that's it.
Lucia:哈哈哈 行行 那
Lucia: Haha, okay, well then...
Lucia:呃那个不远
Lucia: Uh, it's not far.
Lucia:就是还挺近的啊
Lucia: It's actually quite close.
Alice:走路十分钟吧
Alice: About ten minutes walking.
Lucia:那我先把雨轩送过去
Lucia: I'll take Yuxuan there first.
Jake:好 有什么要帮忙的我们就冲过去啊
Jake: Okay, if you need any help, we'll come right over.
Lucia:好的
Lucia: Got it.
Jake:暂且我们先派您一个
Jake: We'll send you first for now.
Lucia:哎就是XBZ那天晚上去
Lucia: So, XBZ went there that night.
Lucia:他其实是搭车过去
Lucia: He actually took a cab there.
Jake:带了伞吗
Jake: Did you bring an umbrella?
Lucia:但是我感觉好像搭车过去
Lucia: But I feel like taking a cab...
Alice:带了
Alice: Yes, I did.
Lucia:就是比我走过去还远
Lucia: ...is actually further than walking.
Lucia:就是它就在这
Lucia: It's right here.
Lucia:其实这个地方
Lucia: Actually, this place...
Lucia:看一眼
Lucia: Take a look.
Alice: 嗯从这拐
Alice: Hmm, turn from here.
Lucia: 从这拐还能更近点
Lucia: Turning from here is even closer.
Lucia: 我第二针下周下周打
Lucia: I'm getting my second shot next week.
Jake: 吃饭
Jake: Let's eat.
Jake: 吃两口
Jake: Have a few bites.
Alice:是不是得先关了
Alice: Should we turn it off first?
Alice: 对我专门问了
Alice: Yeah, I specifically asked.
Lucia: 我说那个要是我不在北京的话
Lucia: I said if I'm not in Beijing...
Lucia: 也可以打
Lucia: I can still get it.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Lucia: 他说可以
Lucia: They said it's fine.
Jake: 走走
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Jake: 呃
Jake: Ugh.
Lucia: 就是但他因为只是个卫生所就比较
Lucia: But since it's just a health center, it's quite...
Lucia: 就比较简简简陋
Lucia: It's quite basic.
Lucia: 稍等我看看
Lucia: 好像还是得这样
Lucia: It seems it has to be this way.
Lucia: 走过去发现这穿过去能近一点
Lucia: Walk over and you'll find it's closer.
Lucia:是的
Lucia: Yes.
Alice:这些
Alice: These?
Lucia: 有点下雨了
Jake: 嗯我不知道哪个是我的呀
Jake: Hmm, I don't know which one is mine.
Lucia: 你和XBZ
Lucia: You and XBZ.
Lucia: 昨天晚上有吃什么一样的东西吗
Lucia: Did you eat anything the same last night?
Lucia: 怎么你们俩都不舒服
Lucia: Why are both of you not feeling well?
Katrina:  他是他好像先是不舒服
Katrina: 然后今天早晨起来就难受
Lucia: 我没听说过这种啊
Katrina: 然后从第二杯开始 我就喝了一点酒
Lucia:平常呃四五十度的样子四十度吧
Lucia: Normally, it's around forty to fifty degrees, about forty degrees.
Lucia:差不多
Lucia: Pretty much.
Katrina: 为什么我喝了那个没事儿
Lucia:理论上这两条也差不多
Lucia: In theory, these two are about the same.
Lucia:就这条路往前拐一下
Lucia: Just take this road and turn a bit ahead.
Lucia: 其实刚那条路这样走也是可以的
Lucia: Actually, the other road we just took works too.
Lucia: 正常能更近一点
Lucia: Normally, it can be closer.
Alice: 真的我觉得比咱那天取快递近
Alice: Really, I think it was closer than picking up the package.
Lucia: 真的 比快递近
Lucia: Really, closer than the package.
Lucia: 所以我觉得
Lucia: So I think...
Lucia: 好像他们搭车走的反而更远一点
Lucia: It seems like taking the car was actually farther.
Lucia: 因为这小路不能走车嘛
Lucia: Because this path doesn't allow cars.
Lucia: 他们要搭车就必须那样子绕
Lucia: If they want to catch a ride, they have to go around.
Lucia: 然后绕到那条路上
Lucia: And then go around to that road.
Lucia: 然后从咱们平常搭车那口
Lucia: Then from the usual spot we catch rides.
Jake:是这个味
Jake: That's the flavor.
Lucia: 走更远了
Lucia: It's even farther.
Jake: 嗯那你那你别回来
Jake: Hmm, then you, you don't come back.
Alice: 你是哪个
Alice: Which one are you?
Alice: 我也不知道你是哪个
Alice: I also don't know which one you are.
Alice: 都不要香菜的吧
Alice: None of them have cilantro, right?
Katrina: 我以为睡一觉好了 然后吃点西瓜排尿 是因为酒精的那个
Lucia: 真打雷了
Lucia: It's really thundering.
Katrina: 应该是肠胃炎
Lucia: 感觉有点像有点像
Lucia: It kind of feels like it, kind of feels like.
Lucia:这麻烦死了挡我视线
Lucia: This is so annoying, blocking my view.
Alice: 你帮我试一下
Alice: Can you help me try it?
Lucia: 我感觉这时间快到了吧
Lucia: I feel like the time's almost up.
Lucia: 让我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Lucia: 给他关掉去
Lucia: Turn it off for him.
Lucia: 这个这个眼镜
Lucia: These glasses.
Lucia: 太挡视线了.
Lucia:好像就差不多这
Lucia: Seems like it's almost there.
Lucia: 再左拐应该就基本上到了
Lucia: Turn left and we should be almost there.
Lucia: 就从这出去
Lucia: Just go out from here.
Lucia: 然后就到了很近
Lucia: And then we're there, it's really close.